Welcome back!
Hello everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome in.
Welcome in.
Welcome in!
Devil may cry.
Minto may cry.
Minto never cry.
Wisp always cry.
Welcome, welcome back.
Oh, she is hungry this time.
Stop it!
Stop with the hungry.
If I get hungry, I have spaghetti.
I can eat.
After talking about Ace Combat, I dragged a lot of attention from the Ace Combat community to your stream.
So say hi.
Hello!
Bow bow time.
It is bow bow time.
Oh gosh.
So I want to say...
Last time, I'm so sorry about before.
I'm feeling much better today.
Will I be any better at the game?
Probably not.
But that's okay.
You know, we...
I'm not alive, but humans live and learn.
I'm dead and I learn sometimes.
I never learn.
I never cry and I never learn.
Minto, it's my birthday.
How am I supposed to say your birthday if your name is anonymous?
That's so silly.
Exist and never learn.
You were kicking ass.
Caught up on the last bot today.
Stay stylish.
Thank you!
Thanks Pyrobot!
Pro tip for beating this boss.
Hit it till it dies.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Mysterious benefactor.
I remember I can switch...
Trickster?
Trickster is the...
Hold on.
This is melee.
This is special trick.
Or special move.
So for this it's like...
Do this in the air, right?
I remember.
Hi Minky.
Hi!
Minto is dead.
Stuck in her waist.
That's a nice slapper right there.
I remember.
I forgot which style switch was in this one.
Royal Guard, Sword Master, Trickster, Gunslinger.
What?
What are my guns?
These are my guns.
Hold on.
How do I...
This is taunt.
How do I get to the menu?
This is lock on.
Trick, gun, sword, royal.
Gun, sword, gun, trick, gun, royal, gun, whatever, gun...
How... What was it to change my weapon?
Guys, I don't remember how to get to the... RT?
No?
LT?
Ah!
Here, here!
LT, LT, LT.
I think I might go to...
Ebony and Ivory for Cerberus.
Our frozen pup.
Our frozen pup dog.
Good luck against Cerberus and beyond.
I'm really happy you're enjoying this wacky woohoo pizza man game.
Do you think you would ever karaoke some of the songs at some point?
I liked what I heard last time during the boss battle.
I do want to say, I do want to reiterate.
If I'm bad at the game, I'm really sorry.
If I mess up and you're trying to yell at me in chat, I'm playing the game.
So if I see your message...
I'm gaming.
I can't read chat all the time.
So, try not to backseat so much.
And if I get something wrong, don't be like, I told you so!
VTuber!
VTuber never read.
Devil never cry.
Fun fact, this game was originally supposed to be RE6.
But Capcom thought Albert Wesker... Albert?
Was too silly so he became Virgil.
I can't tell if any of these are real anymore.
I wore my Minto shirt for good luck on my finals yesterday but I felt dumber.
No!
VTuber, why aren't you good at the game?
First time you play?
Exactly!
Gosh!
Oh my god.
But no, I'm very excited to be back at this.
Honestly, as much as sometimes difficult games frustrate me...
It's always on the path to becoming a better gamer.
I use the frustration and my stubbornness to not give up and to get better.
That's why I had easy mode unlock last stream and I didn't use it.
Because we're on the path.
This is the Minto path of becoming a stronger gamer.
We let our poor decisions and my panic... Oh my gosh, I feel like...
Wasn't it last time I was so close to beating Cerberus?
And then I panicked.
That's okay.
The Minky way.
Yeah!
Backseaters may cry.
Let them cry.
This game is known for being very hard.
I think people were saying no.
It's very hard.
It's very hard because the original only let you choose one way of playing, right?
And then the freestyle kind of, quote unquote, broke the game.
But I still feel that the enemies are kind of difficult.
Could only switch at statues, right.
But it's also just very hard.
The combat system goes hard.
And Cerberus is the hardest?
No, no, no.
I don't believe that.
Don't make me feel hope that I can get through this game.
Cerberus is the big speed bump.
Get past it and you get the hang of it.
It's like, actually filters people.
Cerberus is the real filter.
Oh my gosh, I can't imagine how many kids were playing this game like...
Mom!
Mom, I'll never make it as a gamer!
Okay, I'm just kind of getting a feel of the controls again.
Whoa!
Am I in gun mode?
Was that... Holy moly!
I don't think that really helps us here though, so...
I will remember it, hopefully.
Well, you know, I'd like to just jump around, so...
I probably, you know...
Corporate weebs may cry, year end 2024.
Oh no, year end?
Ganbare!
Final mission, boss is hardest in series.
But you got it, Mito.
Thank you!
Hardest in the series?
Oh gosh...
Well, I'm not gonna think about that.
That's for... future Mito.
Oh, I was saying earlier...
I was so...
Last time...
Last stream was...
I...
I didn't even turn off my Switch, I didn't close the game or anything.
Like I...
I started up my Switch earlier and I was like...
We're still in the same spot!
So...
Thank you Switch-kun for being such a sport.
I don't know why I wouldn't show my name.
It's me, Aimee Nguyen.
Thanks for your birthday song.
Aimee!
That's so weird.
Aimee...
Aimee Mamamoose.
Okay, I'll give you another song.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Aimee.
Happy birthday!
There we go.
Aimee Mamamoose.
Okay.
I'm sipping my tea.
Today...
I was gonna say... Hold on.
I was... I don't know how long I'll go today.
I actually still have to pack and...
And stuff.
So...
You know, we'll see.
We'll see how far we get.
Oh gosh, Ice Guardian's chamber.
One hour stream.
No!
Longer.
I think I can go longer.
90 second stream.
What if Cerberus first try?
Imagine.
If I'm like, I'll end the stream after I beat Cerberus.
First try.
Goodbye everybody.
We'll watch it again.
Yeah.
I love how sassy he is now.
Again.
He's so young!
He's a young'un.
He looks like... so young.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I'm doing audio balancing.
Should be fine.
If it gets too loud, I'll try and...
I'll try and adjust while mid-battle.
Okay.
Oh, this one.
Oh, okay.
I forgot.
I'm not hitting them at all.
I'm not doing anything at all.
Here we go.
I can't say anything.
Wait, how do I?
Oh gosh.
Okay, Trickster has like the fast dodge.
Okay, I'm remembering.
It's coming back to me.
Crazy!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that got me.
Big, big, big, big damage.
Back, back, back!
Okay.
How do I get to the menu?
I can't remember.
I didn't forget lock-on.
I just decided not to use it.
Status.
Status?
What?
Revenge.
Screenshot!
No, don't screenshot!
Okay, I don't think I have any items, do I?
Okay, no.
I have no vital stars.
Because they keep making them more expensive.
So, we're just gonna have to be good at the game.
Oh goodness.
Did that get me?
Honestly, I feel like this is better for...
What the?
Where did that come from?
Oh, we're already at round 2.
Phase 2.
Oh, he's frozen again?
I feel like this is better than locking on.
Oh god!
Move Dante!
Gosh, why is he going to phase 2?
Is there a phase 3?
I'm scared.
Dante, run away!
Maybe I should trickster for that.
Wait, you can't run and change things at the same...
Oh, you can...
Oh, okay, nevermind.
I was wrong.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no!
Okay, I'm still getting used to it.
Oh, this one is gunning.
This one's gunning.
Trickster!
I'm not gonna make it!
Oh my god, there's like nothing that...
Lots of switching.
Yeah, I don't think...
Okay, no.
I don't want to pay for any more vital stars.
Okay.
Gun.
Sword.
Trick.
I don't think...
People were saying that Royal Guard is kind of difficult.
I think...
I think I'm gonna...
Stick to these for now.
The main point of the air combo is actually not the attack itself, but also the fact that it slows your fall.
Yeah, because...
I do notice that, because it's like...
He'll spray the ground and I'll try to jump in the air and not...
You know, get that in the way of that.
You gotta time it perfectly to get the most out of Royal Guard.
The hardest was strongest.
Can I even parry this dog?
Does he do any...
Does he...
Yes!
You can parry anything!
I'll do my best.
What am I...
Sorry, master.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot!
He got me!
He still managed to get me!
Stupid dog.
Jump!
Kind of fumbled that, you guys.
Dog.
Holy shoot!
OK.
Jaxer!
Did I hit me?
I don't know, actually.
OK.
Oh my god, no!
No!
Oh, that's not what I meant to do!
Get him!
OK.
Oi!
Trickster!
Oh gosh.
Speed!
OK.
Jump!
Dante!
Oh no!
Trick!
Speed!
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh!
Guys, I'm not gonna make it!
I'm scared.
I only like to switch between two things.
Oh no!
No, no, no!
I'm scared!
Jump!
Oh gosh!
Trick!
We're getting closer, but...
He's all frozen again!
He's not gonna take any damage!
You stupid dog!
Oh gosh!
Oh!
One HP and a dream!
I gotta remember to switch to my guns...
When I am far away and scared.
NT!
Where am I going?
Camera, can you stop it for a second?
Guns break the ice easier.
Oh really?
Good to know.
So, I'm gonna...
Oh!
OK.
Cool.
Big gains!
I need some help!
That's fine.
You know what?
Oh!
No, no, no!
Trickster!
Oh God!
Oh my God!
OK, I gotta get away from him when he does that.
I gotta get away from him when he does that, for real.
Oh God!
He's gonna charge!
No!
I knew it!
That was mid...
That was mid-attack.
Jump!
And trickster!
Leave!
OK, OK.
Oh gosh!
He's gonna barge, right?
Or he's gonna do his little ice ball, yeah?
There we go.
How do I switch?
Oh, there we go.
It's the press, I remember.
Oh God!
Nice!
Is he gonna charge again?
No, he's backing up, right?
He's doing that weird backup thing.
Jump, jump, jump!
I still managed to...
Oh my God!
Please, I'm trying to jump!
Wow.
How is he not second phase yet?
OK.
I think he's about to be...
Oh shit!
OK, gun.
Gun's in time.
Oh God!
Did he just shoot at me?
Or...
Am I crazy?
Trick, trick, trick, trick!
Trick, trick, trick, trick, trick, trick!
OK.
Oh gosh, OK.
Oh shoot!
I did not even just notice that he was gonna do that.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
OK.
I can't tell sometimes when he's just barking away or if he's about to do something.
Jump, jump!
Almost had him.
That was a pretty good run at the start.
That was pretty good at the start.
Not so bad.
OK.
I'm just gonna start in gunslinger.
I'm going to see if I can beat this before you.
OK, go ahead.
Sure.
OK.
Meant to so bad.
I'm gonna see if I can beat this.
Oh my god.
I didn't even...
Shit.
See, he just kinda like chills there.
I don't know what he's doing.
Holy moly!
How did I manage to avoid that?
I don't know!
Oh shoot!
Oh god, I didn't notice that he was going into...
He's like not super frozen?
Is he...
Oh, can we
like keep styling on him?
There we go.
Jump!
Oh man.
I'm not very good at avoiding that one.
No!
Please stop it!
Oh my god.
Oh god!
Stop, please!
This freaking dog!
Oh, he's back to being...
You messed up!
No!
I don't think this is the friend, you guys.
Oh, whoops.
Chill dog, damn.
That's what I'm saying.
You can buy a vital star if you want.
How much was it?
Maybe I should.
Don't forget you have stinger.
Oh, how did I use that?
How do I use that again?
It's...
Hold on.
I don't remember.
Nice try, restart NTR.
Let's not normalize that.
Lock on forward melee.
Can I do that as trickster too?
Oh, I can.
Okay,
I'm gonna buy one.
But I'm only gonna use it if I really think the run is salvageable.
I'll only use it if I think the run is salvageable.
I could've bought a blorb.
Maybe that would've been better.
Well, I've already made my choices.
I've made my choices.
Come here, pup.
Puppy dog.
Alright.
What was it?
Lock on.
Melee.
Oh, it doesn't really do much, does it?
Maybe a sword master does more?
I guess it's just the legs, huh?
I'm not doing anything.
I'm doing no damage, you guys.
Was I not doing it right?
Oh, nice.
Come on, come on, come on, come on!
He's down, he's down!
Get him while he's down!
Oh god, he's about to...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he's back.
Okay.
He's charging, he's charging!
I don't know why I was like, Oh yeah, he's charging, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Oh, no.
Shit!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
I did the wrong thing anyway.
Wait.
Move, move, move, move, move!
Dante!
I can't tell.
I'm really bad at reading his movements.
Okay, he does like twice on each side.
Run, run, run, Dante!
Run!
Oh, he's gonna charge, he's gonna charge!
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
How am I...
Guys?
How am I alive?
I'm actually...
It's pixel perfect.
One HP.
Do I use it, you think?
I don't think it'll...
I think I should've bought the L-Star.
Yeah, I'm using my GameShark right now.
Not worth it.
Yeah.
Don't use it.
I mean, it's for sure I'll die, but...
You should not have bought any.
Oh my god.
Why the hell did you do that, you stupid dummy?
You stupid bee.
If I were playing, I wouldn't have bought a single one.
Oh god, okay.
Should've bought the W-Star.
Instead of the L-Star.
Sorry, I'm stalling because...
I'm shaking because I get nervous about fights.
Okay.
Oh, I'm stalling.
I'm stalling.
Chip with guns.
Maybe if I stay away and just...
Watch me die instantly.
This'll be so funny.
Oh, we lost a head!
Wait, we're doing big damage.
Oh shit.
Guys, I think I want to use my star.
I think I want to use my star actually.
I think so.
I'm scared.
I'm not ready.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
God, I keep doing this.
Oh shit.
No, get the head.
There we go.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
I didn't even need to use the star!
I'll take that as a 1 HP.
Yay!
I harness his power?
What is that?
Oh, we're nunchuking!
Well done, Minky.
Thank you!
Cerberus!
A weapon of three interlocking rods infuses the elemental power of ice!
Yay!
Change devil arms.
Oh, in freestyle mode you can freely change the devil arms by using R while pressing ZR.
Press ZR and alternate devil arms in a clockwise fashion.
Oh yeah, give me my robes.
Look, we made back our money!
I've been bested.
Take my soul and move forward.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
Yay, I love Gunslinger!
I'm so glad I played DMC2!
This nunchuk's revolver move is my favorite move in the entire...
Nunchuk's revolver?
My favorite bit about DMC3 is the bosses are like, you're pretty good, use my soul and go kick ass in style.
Should I sword master with it?
Seems like a pretty good weapon.
But I can't stinger with it.
What other abilities do we have?
Wait, can I like, go back to the...
I'm assuming there's a statue this way.
I might be assuming wrong.
I might be dumb.
No
gaming!
This game...
I never know what's going to happen next.
No way!
I thought he was just going to Matrix style it but...
Heterochromia.
Hello Yuna.
He's so calm and cool and galactic.
Oh.
Yeah, it does Dante.
Agreed baby!
Freestyle.
Could've been better.
S.
Stylish point C.
D.
V.
You can do that in game if I...
No way.
I got a C for...
C.
Told you you could do it.
Status files, dev alarms will show you all the combos you've unlocked so far.
Oh, thanks Nicholas!
Actually yeah.
I don't want to redo the fight.
Let's go.
My brother.
He's in galaxy, he's in space.
Oh my god, his eyes are kind of bugging.
He's like, a woman?
No girls allowed in my tower.
Oh.
You want to know how I got these scars?
Wait, they're moving.
Wait, that's actually so cool.
He said the thing?
Is that his thing?
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
A storm is approaching.
The uninvited one.
Find the key to the stars.
Dante treats this whole thing like a party.
So of course a party only gets better when a chick goes too.
Dante, my brother.
Action, that's what I wanted to say.
Cerberus.
Revolver!
Wait, it's actually called Revolver.
And Windmill.
15,000, we're just a little bit short.
I'm kind of close to Air Hike.
I think I was saving up for Air Hike last time.
Stinger 2 is real good.
I could get that.
But I want to try Cerberus a little bit.
My guns.
What was it?
Wait.
How was it to see the combos again?
Understand.
No.
Action, thank you.
Wait.
Oh, it's got to be in the, oh wait, is that under information?
R, forward, X.
Status file, Devil Arms.
Okay, so it's a little bit different.
Okay, I'll do it when we start the game.
That's kind of sick.
Doors casually on fire, you know how it is.
Map screen.
Get in your bearings.
Select the map from the status screen.
Overhead view of the map shows your surrounding area from over perspective.
Freeze frame shows a graphical image from the room you currently occupy.
Side view.
Okay.
Thanks, Kim.
Status.
File.
Devil Arms.
Thanks for the gift, thank you.
Rebellion.
Oh, X, X, X.
Naughty.
Rebellion combo.
X, pause, X, X.
Helm breaker.
X in the middle area.
Stinger.
R, forward, X.
High time.
Hold X to jump.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Million stab.
Press X repeatedly while executing a type 2 combo.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, wait.
And we haven't done anything really.
Oh, we know high time.
Element of ice.
X, X, X, X, X.
Come on.
X, X, pause.
X, X.
Swing.
X midair.
Revolver.
R, X, forward.
Okay.
X, X, X, X, X.
So many X.
X, X, X, X, X, X.
Repeatedly press X while executing a type 2 combo.
Okay.
I'll try to remember.
X, X, pause.
X, X.
X, X, X.
X, X, X, X.
Press X to combo.
Wait, oh.
This looks like it's, you know, breakable or something.
No?
What is this place anyway?
What is this?
Wait.
Can I run up walls or am I crazy?
This looks like a place to run up.
Ahem.
You had wall jump with trickster.
It appears to be an elevator shaft.
Oh.
Okay.
Well, maybe we'll use it later.
This seems to be, you just walk around it.
We'll just ignore that for now.
Okay, there was the door that it showed, but...
I will not give up an opportunity to grab a orb.
Oh, there's the door.
It's on the other side.
Let's see.
What is that sound?
What is that clacky sound?
I see something here.
Oh.
Ah.
How do we...okay, hold on.
Do we go up from this way?
Tick tock?
What's a clock?
Tick tock on the clock.
Alright.
XXX.
Mint disgusting girlfriend.
I have
to be quiet.
There are so many surprises for you to encounter.
Yeah, no spoilers.
Massive stone wall bars your path.
You cannot proceed.
What?
Oh, there's just a orb down there.
I was about to miss it.
Nice.
What the hell is that sound?
It's over here.
Maybe?
Oh.
Oh, well, I made it.
I just...not yet.
How do I get to there?
Sneaky off-screen orb.
There was another one over here too.
I saw it.
Was there anything up here?
This one is blue and the other one is gold.
Oh.
Oh, well...
I did get it.
Dante, can you, like, grab onto a ledge, please?
I think...
I'm stupid.
Can I do that over ledges?
I don't remember how to...hold on.
She has arthritis.
I don't think...
I'm so sorry, Dante.
Fantastic.
I can't use this mid-air.
That kind of sucks.
You can dash forward toward a ledge.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm still trying to get...
Thank you.
Still remembering controls and all that.
What is the clock that I'm hearing?
If I fall here...
Why don't I hear it anymore?
Hmm.
My Yoshi is lost.
I'm not lost!
I'm trying to figure out how to get this dang item over here.
Well, I guess let's just try the door first.
Is that where I'm hearing the noise from?
Try and get me!
I'm having a blast.
Beat it for blast.
Oh yeah, we gotta taunt so we can get some...
Here, let's get one for the thumbnail.
Alright Dante, say cheese!
What?
I can't break these?
They offer me nothing?
Oh no.
Red is defeat all enemies, right?
Or is it the puzzle one?
Oh.
Red is kill.
Oh my gosh, it's kind of awesome.
Wait, I remember these guys from last time.
I avoided them like the plague.
Crazy combo!
During certain circumstances, you can repeatedly press a button to execute a special high-speed combo attack.
Press X repeatedly while performing the stinger.
Oh yeah, the...
Gunslinger, press...
Repeatedly press Y near a downed enemy.
From mission 3, yeah.
Sobinox!
Welcome to my membership!
Thank you!
Okay.
I can't see anything!
Oh shoot!
Which is a good idea actually.
Oh damn.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Shoot!
Camera, I can't...
Jump!
Dodge!
Dodge and jump!
Okay, hold on, this is...
Oh no, okay.
Oh my god.
Why is the dodge so slow?
Oh shit.
I'm not good at timing this, huh?
Level 1 dodge.
Wait, actually, is that what it is?
Oh, I got one though.
Let's go.
No.
Wait, there's another one!
No, bro!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Give me the robes, please.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
No, no.
That guy.
I think I can get him from...
Can they reach me?
I wonder.
What the...
Oh, I'm on gunslinger.
I got...
Oh my god.
Camera, please!
Oh god!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die in here.
I'm gonna freaking die in here.
No, please!
Oh gosh!
Oh my god, please.
I'm just trying to run.
Oh, this thing.
Oh no!
He's not dead, is he?
Oh, shit.
Oh, shoot.
Which I will do.
I'll just try and kill him.
Okay.
It's...
No, just go up and hit them.
He's using a gun.
I have no...
I should have never used my...
Star.
I should have never used my star in the last thing.
Run, Dante!
Run!
Icky.
Icky is stupid.
Wait, how many robes do I have now?
I might be able to buy air hike.
Oh, 14.
Just kidding.
Like...
No!
Minto may cry.
Minto will cry.
Remember you can change weapon mid-combo.
That sounds really hard for my hands.
Like...
Mid-combo?
Didn't you say you couldn't cry?
I couldn't cry.
It sounds harder than it is, really?
Okay.
It's my birthday today!
Would I be able to get a happy birthday?
Keeping your adorable self a day with the mainstream is always a good one.
Solidus Skink!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Solidus Skink.
Happy birthday!
Okay.
Come here, you.
Oh, just...
I never got caught with the nunchucks, I'm just saying.
What was it that you can...oh wait.
You can press Y when you're in Gunslinger with a guy that's down.
I wanna try that too.
Okay.
How do I want to do...
Wait.
Which one is it for...
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Great thing about restarts is you keep the rorbs and experience points for your style from enemies.
Yeah, that's why, honestly, it's not so bad.
I mean it's bad, but it's not the worst.
It could be the worst.
But it's not the worst.
They give you a little bit of a...
leeway.
These guys though, I hate them.
I hate these guys a lot, actually.
They're tough.
They're really tough.
Oh my god.
See, I can't even...I can't even get a movement without them firing at me.
Oh, gosh.
No, please.
And how do I get this guy more easily?
Wait.
I'm doing the wrong thing.
There we go, this is what I'm trying to do.
Okay, nice.
And then, the guys manifest.
Yeah.
Then we have these guys manifesting.
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Dodgey!
Okay, I think I got him.
Nice, okay.
Okay, awesome.
They're jumping at me.
Nice.
Keep the... Oh, my rorbs are down here!
Messed up!
Nice.
Breakdown.
Okay, let's go get the other guy.
Oh my gosh.
I love Stinger!
Oh, nice.
Okay, perfect.
There's still more, but where are they?
That would explain that.
Nice.
Oh, my rorbs!
That one was so much better than the first try.
This try was so much better than the first try.
Okay.
To the being with the will of the thunderstorm, I bestow the soul of steel.
Thunderstorm.
Stinger is always the way to go.
I should have never doubted.
Stinger, my beloved.
Thunder.
Do I know any moves that do thunder?
The stole.
Shut up.
The will of the thunderstorm.
No Alastor yet.
You don't have it yet.
I'll be back for you, my precious.
I don't even know what that is.
But it's shiny and I do want it.
Silent Sanctuary.
I'm afraid of doing anything with that yet.
Oh, these do break.
Of course they do.
Breakdown.
Give me everything.
I'm robbing this place for all it's worth.
Yes!
We have enough!
We have enough for air hike.
Let's go.
Money, money.
Make the money babe.
What's up there?
OK, let's do this.
I'm on?
We're going high.
We're going all the way up to the top, baby.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh, I'm not even close to him.
There we go.
Who else?
Oh, there's a lot of them.
Oh god, what is he doing?
Let's get this guy first.
Get out of my way.
You're throwing off my groove.
Oh shoot.
Nice.
Watch out!
Oh, someone else came in.
Who are you?
Oh, there's two of them.
Oh my god.
I have a... I have a...
Can you... OK, Dante, when you do that, you need to actually be hitting them.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there we go.
Is there anything up here?
Where these guys came from, even?
There's a blorb, I think.
How do I get all the way up there?
Style on them.
We're styling.
There we go.
Easy.
I don't even need to be Trickster.
I'm too good at this game.
It only took me an hour plus for one boss, but...
That's just how the cookie gets eaten.
Got it.
Oh, there it is.
And there they are.
Oh, they're right here.
In front of me.
Nice.
Don't fall.
Oh, there's... Oh no!
OK.
Wait, I do have to go up there.
OK, hold on, let's see.
Relaxing low-key.
Yeah.
Oh, come on, Dante!
Dante.
Dante, use your big boy legs.
Come on, buddy.
Grab!
Wait a second.
Can I just double jump here?
Oh, I'm an idiot.
I was making it more difficult for myself.
Give me the money.
What is this thing anyway?
It's freaky.
I thought I was going to fall all the way down to the bottom.
What is this?
A tablet with a round indentation lies in front of a large rotating gear.
Large metal gear, you would say?
One would call it... that... word.
Not now, Mint.
I'm watching DMC3.
You're right, sorry.
Wait, where did the other door go?
Oh,
now I've done it.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, OK.
We're right here.
There.
Actually, this is faster.
Hello?
I'm scared.
Oh my God.
Oh shoot, it's this thing.
Shoot, it's this thing.
Oh God, oh God, oh God.
Stay down!
Oh my God, these guys are so...
Oh my God.
I'll chill.
I'll chill, chill, chill.
Stop, leave me alone.
Can I get my orbs over here?
Thank you.
Gosh, they're so fast.
So fast.
Oh, there's another guy.
Oh God, oh God, oh God.
Oh no, no, no, please.
Please, another one.
Oh my God, no, no, that's not...
Oh God, I'm gonna die in here.
I'm gonna die in here.
I'm gonna die.
I survived.
What?
What about the stairs though?
Steal thy soul.
The future knows no bounds for those who deftly march forth to meet it.
Does that mean I shouldn't have taken the stairs?
Health is not high enough.
Oh God.
Can I get on top of it?
Get up on the Hydra's back.
Where'd he go?
I'll just wait for him to come back, I guess.
Now...
Oh, that was close, wasn't it?
I
think he was getting electric again.
Can't see anything.
I think he's here.
Oh, you jerk.
It's weak to ice?
Wait, it is?
Wait,
didn't I switch?
Oh, I forgot in this game I could change camera angles.
I don't think I'm gonna make it though.
Oh, this is different.
This is new.
Oh?
I can't reach.
Why did I change the camera angle?
I can't see anything.
Where do you think he's gonna come from?
Oh, he's already...
Oh, shoot!
Oh gosh, I'm dumb.
I can't see anything!
Oh God.
Uh...
Okay.
Patience.
Patience, everybody.
Oh my God.
Oh, stupid bug.
Stupid depth perception.
My depth perception can't handle things like this.
Oh my God!
I can't see anything!
He's so kind to me.
It's the camera too, it really is.
It really is.
I'm doing my best!
In the end I just ended up shooting my gun.
Uh...
I can't see anything!
Oh my God.
Okay, at least I was able to get some hits in.
My goodness.
She is sharp.
Okay.
Oh, he's all the way up there.
Oh, come on!
Oh, there we go.
Get his little butt!
Okay.
Okay!
Alright!
Keep at it, Dante!
I don't know how we fell off, but I guess we did.
What's happening?
What's wrong with villain?
What's wrong, villain?
Oh, I
keep...
Yeah, Minto fell off.
Is
there any grorbs in this room?
Anything?
I don't want to get in front of the door, it will attack me.
I don't have my vital star, do I?
I don't have one, you guys.
I don't have a star.
Why do you think I had a star?
I have none.
Why did you guys think I had one?
Oh, well...
Get out of the way!
Enough for air, Haika.
That would be so helpful here.
Oh, gosh.
The camera is the biggest enemy here, for real.
Oh, and there we go.
How far do we start from?
Oh, from here.
Okay.
What's
my...
The camera is bad, but you're trying to jump on him from awkward spots.
There's like three spots I can jump on him from.
There's like the higher ones and then the lower ones.
Try to use lock-on for the boss?
Okay.
I will try.
Is there... maybe if I go back...
Wasn't there...
Where's the map?
Is that it?
No?
Wasn't there a guy...
Oh, it's at the very bottom though, isn't it?
There's a statue only at the very bottom.
I'd have to go back through all the rooms, wouldn't I?
That's far.
Alright, we'll just do it.
What's my health at though?
I wish I could see.
Oh, it's full.
That would be so good, you guys.
We got this.
He's kind of cool.
Where's a better spot to jump on to him then?
Maybe here?
There's not many spots I feel.
I can't...
Oh, maybe here is better.
The bridge there.
Yeah, yeah.
I got it.
I just...
I just need to not miss.
Oh, nice.
Nice dodge.
Come back!
Ok,
I can't change the camera here, so...
Couldn't get his little butt.
No!
I keep doing this.
Oh my god.
I keep jumping or I keep...
I keep attacking too soon.
Ok, ok, ok.
Get his butt!
Big damage!
Nice.
That was good.
And he's gonna purple.
And I jump!
And I...
How did I get such big damage before?
How did I get all that big damage?
Jump!
Nice.
Chipping him away.
Deflecting the balls.
I see, I see.
Which he might do again.
Oh!
Hey, buddy!
Did it again, kinda.
I'm a baseball player.
Oh, nice!
We got some damage in.
Good, good, good, good, good, good.
We're doing it, guys.
We're doing it.
Slowly, but surely.
Did you play college ball?
Yeah.
Cracking...
What was it?
I don't remember what he said.
Oh my god.
You guys, he drinks me!
University text.
I wish I could see.
We kind of got him a little bit.
Oh gosh though, am I gonna survive?
I wish he would stop with the purple.
Let me just chip you away, please.
Oh shit, man!
Is it...
Is it easier to do it with not the nunchucks?
Here I thought we would be okay, but...
Will we dodge that?
Reflect with the guns?
I can do that?
I don't think I can do that!
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move.
Oh god.
At this point I don't feel like I can even jump on him to get any attack and like...
Oh
my god, I thought I was about to die!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Oh gosh.
My robs!
How rude of you.
Clutch of the century.
Damn, that was so...
Dang.
Astronomical board.
An astrological device which displays the endless void.
Said to be powered by time.
We know where that goes.
Good job, Binky.
You beat that boss in under 5 tries without crying, farting, or puking.
How do you know I didn't fart?
Not even you can open that door, Dante.
He's like, I know your game, door.
Lad?
What the hell is this?
His nose has jiggle physics.
No good!
What the heck?
I could have used a trigger warning for this guy.
This place...
Or is that too difficult for you?
Dante is so unserious.
That is what the something is.
Remember that, kid?
Write it down on your hand if you don't trust your head.
I see.
Thanks.
You still piss me off, though.
I could have used a warning for Jester.
I have 300 hours in this game.
I never knew you could deflect those.
What?
Thanks for making me learn something new, Mintominkymonkey.
You're welcome.
You guys, we killed it!
We're so awesome!
Nice.
Mission 5 of Devils and Swords.
Unleash your might on the demonic gatekeepers.
I just got here.
How was the millipede fight?
It was okay.
I clutched it, as I always do.
I'm too good!
I'm too good.
Girl boss.
Gaslight.
Gatekeepers.
This game is so cute, isn't it?
It's so cute.
Alright, customize, baby.
Let's buy some...
Air hike.
And we have enough for something else, maybe.
Not that.
Devil Minto cute.
That?
Spin the nunchucks around in a propeller-like motion to rapidly slice into the enemy.
R, L, back, X.
Blorb?
How much is a blorb?
I think blorb was...
10,000?
Yeah, we do not have enough for a blorb.
I guess I can save up for the blorb.
Windmill is alright.
Gun upgrade.
Maybe.
I think I'll save up for blorb.
I will probably always need more health.
It's a bit early, but when you finish the game, I hope you get to see some of the DMC3 combo AMV...
AMV?
It's cheesy fun and shows how nuts Dante can get.
What?
For a new player, yeah, blorb is good.
I think I should need it.
Look at that guy.
I like the way the blorb looks though.
This is my interpretation of each orb.
That's how each one would sound.
Do you even need gold orbs in this game?
I feel like so far, it doesn't restart you at the very beginning of the mission, so it's not so bad.
Not in gold mode.
That's good then.
Something we don't have to think about using our orbs on.
Oh wait, what does the orb look like?
I need to make the orb...
And then...
And then the vital star...
And the devil star...
Oh wait, the devil star is the orb, but flipped.
So it would make the opposite...
Hey chat, which orb is getting the best head?
The blorb.
He's ready.
But I think...
The blorb...
Is also like...
What is your favorite color flavor?
I think the blorb looks really delicious.
I love blue flavor.
But actually I think...
Blue flavor might be my favorite flavor.
Binto sound effects pack mod win.
Where did Binto come from?
Oh, what did I do?
Oh, I went to...
Ebony and Ivory.
I can't stop yawning.
I'm sorry guys.
Okay.
Blorb is pogging.
Red flavor.
Now we're buddies!
Wait...
We're buddies!
The worst boss in the game?
Really?
Like in terms of just...
How...
Not fun it is?
I was expecting something a little better from this.
What's that thing?
S?
Oh, why am I...
Come on!
What am
I...Oh my goodness, they hit hard.
Oh gosh!
Oh, is that because we're in mission 5 or whatever?
Isn't there one hidden in every level?
I remember now.
But I forgot to look for it before.
Wait, I have air hike now, right?
Oh my gosh, stop!
Oh, they're fast.
They're fast!
Am I gonna die to these birds?
That would be really unfortunate if I did.
Let her figure it out.
Uh-oh, am I missing something?
Oh, I died!
Were they actually multiplying?
Oh no, go on him.
And do I...
Oh wait, not that.
Wait, not that, my bad.
Oh, it eventually comes back to life.
Okay.
Oh shoot, no, no, stop!
Stop it!
Come on, I'm trying to figure it out.
Ah!
I did kill him!
I think?
Wait, actually I'm not sure.
Is there another guy?
Oh, there is!
Oh, there's tons of them.
Ah, shoot.
Oh my god, no, this guy.
Right here?
Nice, got him right before.
Oh, what is he doing?
Can I change to you?
Thank you.
And you, and you, and you, and you, and you.
Gosh, they unfreeze so fast.
They split apart.
Yeah, I'm very much seeing that.
Ah!
Ah, jeez.
Jeez louise.
Finally.
Is there anything else in here?
Oh wait, this is where our little guy was.
It won't let us go the other way.
What's this?
Hello?
Enter it like a door.
Oh, so I actually like...
No!
Oh no!
Oh god.
That's so cute!
Oh, what is that?
Oh god.
Right in the balls!
Holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy.
Oh.
Oh, again.
Please.
More balls!
Too many balls.
Can I hit these at him?
I don't want to try though.
Holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy.
I
don't know if I'm doing this correctly, but...
It's kind of silly.
Oh gosh, there's... Oh no, no!
So many balls!
Too many balls!
We do big damage with this though.
Nice.
Okay.
More balls.
Oh, three balls!
What are the green ones?
What are the green ones special for?
Holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy.
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
My name.
Holy...My name!
Holy, holy, holy, holy...
Cool name.
I'll take it.
What the hell was that?
Welcome back to my membership!
Thank you!
Thank you Angel Wings!
Holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy...
Okay.
We got the thing that we put...
Onto the clock.
Freak off.
I would win.
The robes returned.
How kind.
That's cool.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Another gift.
Thank you.
I would...Oh wow, there is one down there.
You see it?
Do you see it?
I didn't know you had a cameo in this game.
Holy, holy, holy, holy...
Use the astronomical board.
What is it doing?
What
does that mean?
What does that mean?
Where was the roar?
Is it further down?
Jump on?
It's funny?
Okay.
Here I go!
Roar!
The devil, devil, devil trampoline.
Let's go.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
And...roar.
Roar.
And roar.
And more roar.
Perfect.
Oh yeah, the thing that had...I was like, I've already lost the sauce.
Or lost the plot.
I was...
Getting the wall that came down.
Was it over this right here?
Lost in the sauce.
We got a fork!
Say it.
The Vajurra.
We got the Vajurra.
Glad to catch the stream.
Hope you feel much better.
Boss, good luck and have fun.
Thank you, Neo Cerberus.
Oh, I almost said Cerberus.
Ceribus.
I almost said, I almost said, I was like Cerberus.
Whoa, Panzer, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Model of an ancient weapon used to control lightning.
This is merely an ornament.
Control lightning, eh?
Was it this door?
I need more health.
I guess we're okay.
I don't know why I shot.
Sorry, I'm still thinking up.
Oh, they come from the walls.
Wow, we're really silent.
I like
that we can get this one from backwards too.
It's nice.
Oh no, no, no, don't disappear.
I lost it.
I don't know the combos for this.
Hold on.
File.
Devil Arms.
Cerberus.
So it was...
Just a bunch of X's.
X, X.
Okay, X, X, pause.
And then the rebellion one was X, pause, X.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Gosh, I don't... You can tell I don't play fighting games.
X midair.
X won't go... Oh, target and X forward.
Okay, that's right.
Okay, I got a target more.
They're not gonna respawn, are they?
Revolver.
Dante.
Here we go.
Oh, my bad.
Use the Majura.
Majura.
Not so violently, Dante!
Oh my gosh.
Sky.
He has not a sensitive bone in his body.
We got the Soul of Steel.
That's what it talked about.
The essence of a powerful and fearless soul.
Its possessor need not fear hell nor oblivion.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Let me scratch my nose first.
Okay, wait, where are these guys?
Oh my god, please.
Let's just kill this guy first.
Somehow.
Who's yelling?
I think I killed it.
Nice.
Oh, can I lock on to you, please?
Come on, come on.
There we go.
Breakdown.
Nice.
Grab my robes.
Thanks for meeting me.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for coming down here.
Ouchie.
Can you die already?
I almost missed the stairs.
Oh gosh, why do I always have to fall?
I keep falling.
Thanks.
Oh, shut up door.
This guy is just chilling all by himself up here.
Is that the last one?
Million stab is just for sunlocking a style point.
Yeah, I was styling on them.
A lot, probably too much.
They were like dead dead, but I just like to show them who's boss.
That's why the other guys die so fast, because they are cowering in fear.
Styling.
So we got this thing.
This idle animation.
He becomes Sonic the Hedgehog.
We got the soul.
What do we do with this thing?
How do I see what the mission is?
Does the map tell me the mission?
No.
The stole.
Yeah, we got the stole.
Walk across the gap.
Does file work?
No, or...
No, it doesn't have a...
They told you to steal that?
Oh, that's right.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
The writing on the wall.
The literal writing on the wall.
Wait, wrong way.
Wait, right way?
Right way.
Oh, thank goodness for giving me...
Oh, dang it.
Should have parried that.
Dante and Sonic the Hedgehog are distant relatives.
My uncle works at Nintendo.
I just realized how soon until your concert.
Good luck.
Thank you!
I'm so nervous, you guys.
I might throw up.
I'm so nervous for the concert!
I don't want to think about it.
Let's go take our little...
This guy.
Bang!
Nice.
Was it this door?
Astral Chamber?
Oh, no.
Which way was it?
Next door up?
The
door over here.
I like the angle there.
It's really cool.
Is it...
Am I silly?
One floor down.
I'm stealing my soul!
Will it work?
Maybe...hold on.
I'm stealing my soul!
There's more where this came from if you throw up on Doki.
Ah!
Use the stole...I keep saying stole.
Use the soul of steel!
The statue?
Yeah, I'll get it.
Don't worry, I see it.
I don't know what it is, but...
Oh, I am the combat...
Oh, only a technique?
OK.
Oh, that's right.
I have to do like a cool...
Wait, how many pauses was it?
XX pause XX?
Right?
XX pause XX!
XX!
Oh, it's melee.
Oh, you're right.
Sorry.
Blast?
Oh, turn around?
No, I lost my combo!
Hold on, I have to get up.
There we go.
XX pause XX!
You can't use sword here, because it said only icy.
Come on!
So close!
Finally!
Goodness gracious.
Yay!
If you get nervous at the concert, just imagine...
Everyone in their underwear.
And the men as minotaurs.
And the girls boneless.
We got a full blow!
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, back to sword.
Surge of Fortunas.
The little children are laughing at me.
Wait, what do I... What's this one?
Oh!
Defeat all enemies while taking no damage?
Get me out of here!
I don't want to do this!
Oh screw this.
No, come on man.
I don't want to do this.
No!
Exit speedrun maybe?
Thank you so much for the...
Yay!
I think I'm good.
Nobody saw that right?
Anyway...
What would Jeff do?
You guys sure seem to like Jeff!
Zaki, thanks for the gift!
Oh no!
Oh god!
I was going to say, are we going to get...
I was literally about to say, are we about to get ambushed on the elevator?
God dammit.
No, please!
Please don't fall off!
Stupid skellies!
You assholes!
Ruined my ride!
I tried to parry.
I was weak.
Anyway, my god.
Oh, I have to do it again.
I
think they'll respawn?
I sure hope not.
Okay, anyway.
Yeah, go away.
I'm not even going to get my rorbs.
Literal lazy bones.
Ouch!
My rorbs!
All my rorbs!
All my rorbs.
So sad.
Where are we?
Invisible wall.
My money.
Is there... I asked this earlier and if someone said I didn't see it, is there a way to...
Is there a way to see what the mission is?
Nice view.
At the statue.
Save?
Oh, save to see your current mission.
Okay, perfect.
It didn't say.
Mission is to go to the top of the tower.
Thanks for the membership.
A later thanks.
Sorry.
I'm glad you got one, Jarin.
Oh, there's a statue right there!
Oh my god.
No way.
You guys, it was literally right under our nose.
What can we buy?
Blorb?
That's a good idea.
That is a good idea.
We are blorbing it up.
Yeah, baby!
Air hike?
I already have it.
If you literally watch two seconds, you see that I have air hike.
We gotta get blorbed, everybody.
Next, we'll go for stinger level 2.
Why is the air hike in red?
Is it a triple jump?
Next, we'll go for stinger...
Number 2!
Can't stop yawning.
Oh, because it's already bought.
I see.
This looks breakable.
Nevermind.
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
That's right!
The gatekeepers!
The gaslighters!
The girlbossers!
The gatekeepers!
Oh my god, they have tiny, teeny little heads.
Oh, that's not their body.
You had all this time.
They are yappers.
Wants to go through.
Got it.
They are like big...
Oh shoot!
Nice parry!
Oh god, not nice parry.
I don't know who I should go after first.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh god, that doesn't sound good.
That
one's down.
I see, I see.
And now he's down.
Nice.
Not
down.
I think they are throwing their soul?
Oh, I can't see anything, please.
Oh my god, no!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna see!
It's over.
Are they... Do they have friendly fire?
Ouchie!
Oh, I'm cornered.
Oh my god, the freaking inverted camera kills me every time!
Air hike is saving my butt here.
Oh!
Until it doesn't.
Ouch, oh god.
Oh, they go to this side now.
Oh god.
Actually good try, thank you.
Really good try, thank you.
They are weak to ice damage?
Say no more.
Wait, but my air hike!
No, my air hike!
Ok, we are gonna have to...
We are gonna...
And then...
And then we are gonna...
And then we'll...
Oh, wait.
Give me a second, I'm gonna go get some more...
Drink.
I'm gonna get some more tea.
I'm starting to get a headache.
So, I might also make some...
Heat up some spaghetti.
And we might have a slight intermission.
If that's ok.
Ok, so like my...
I ate like at a weird time today.
So I was like, oh shoot.
I'm gonna get hungry during stream.
So, intermission!
Intermission, but I'll be back.
And then I'll eat my spaghetti.
All good.
You guys just listen to the...
Lovely sounds of the wind.
BRB.
Dinner time.
Hold on.
Dinner time everybody.
Sorry.
That I have to have my dinner.
Midstream.
My bad.
Spaghetti.
I just have some left over spaghetti.
But, I'm sad because it's like...
Super plain spaghetti.
I cook my...
I usually add like a chicken sausage to it.
And onion.
But I ate all the onion when I had it the first night.
And all the sausage.
I would have to recook a new sausage and new onion.
So it's just super plain spaghetti.
But yeah, are you guys having a good week?
It's hump day.
It's one day.
Are you gonna watch the game award show tomorrow?
Probably...
Sometime.
What time is it at?
Tomorrow.
I just wanna know about Astro Boy.
Astro Boy.
Astro Bot.
8pm EST-ish.
I don't think I'll be able to at the time.
But if anything interesting happens, you can tag me on Twitter.
I want to see if Bakura wins.
Right!
Right?
It'll be huge if she does.
Flying out for Iowa tomorrow.
Excited to see you.
Let's go!
Astro Bot.
Yeah, unfortunately I won't be able to stream it.
Because I will also be headed out.
To the area.
Since the concert is this weekend.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
I need a napkin.
Ugh.
Astro Boy was originally Adam.
Adam.
I have tendonitis because of intermission.
Wait, what?
Like tendonitis.
Time to pop Okayu's ult.
Mogu mogu mogu.
At the bar.
At a bar with half battery another hour before a ride can show up.
Oh wait, at a bar.
Oh wait, villain, what happened?
Something happened with your car?
This is how I thought dinner with Mint would go.
Wait, this is not how I thought dinner with Mint would go.
What happened?
Okay.
His car got stuck in the snow.
Vtuber did not read.
I was playing the game and the super chat went too fast.
Oh wait.
The chain broke.
Engine belt broke.
Stop watching stream and call for help.
Did you know that Ace Combat Dev also go to US military to show it on their official Project Ace account?
I believe the USS is a secret visit.
I didn't know.
Wait, I think I saw you tag me or you send me that on Twitter.
Get some help.
It's a joke Minto, don't worry.
I wasn't worried or anything.
What are you talking about?
Okay, real talk.
Is there a strat for these guys?
For the...
What's the strat for these big bozos?
Tickle them.
Parry.
Parry the platypus.
A platypus.
Parry the
platypus.
Cerberus spam to parry easy.
I did actually.
I was getting those parries.
When it was those purple balls.
I got squirrels in my pants.
S-I-M-P.
Squirrels in my pants.
I like the guy who made...
What's it called?
Phineas and Ferb.
The guy that voices the Doofenshmirtzman.
I see him sometimes on TikTok.
You guys, if TikTok gets banned...
You'll never hear me talk about TikTok again.
My mindless entertainment.
Actually, I use my TikTok a lot now for like...
Room inspo and furniture and stuff.
So now I'm like...
What do I have to do?
Make a Pinterest for real or something?
Buff Doofenshmirtz in anime.
What do you mean by that?
Are you talking about...
Dr. Stone?
Dr. Doofminto.
On their bingo.
It's almost 2025.
Gosh, it's almost 2025.
You guys were almost halfway through the month already.
That's crazy.
YouTube Shorts is just as good.
Half the stuff is copied from TikTok.
That's so true.
You interested in the Soul Reaver 1 and 2 remasters?
Actually, I kind of am.
I don't know if I will play them.
But I was watching a thing...
About the...
How they had the...
The audition tape still.
For Soul Reaver.
And how...
And how like...
So much of the cast of Metal Gear also auditioned.
The voice acting in that game is so goaded.
It's so awesome.
Hmm.
Would have been around the same time, yeah, right?
I'm almost done with my spaghetti, by the way, guys.
Sorry.
Thank you for letting me break a little bit.
But I've never played it before.
So, it's not off the table.
But...
I think I have some other stuff that I want to try first.
Like, I think...
I think...
Indiana Jones shouldn't be so, so long.
Probably like 2 or 3 more streams.
And then...
Thank you, I wasn't planning on attending AWA since I did AMYC this year.
But since tickets for the concert still were on sale, I decided to lock in last minute and just show up for that.
Can't wait.
What?
Really?
Thank you!
There's other stuff too going on.
Have fun.
Um...
What's for dinner?
Dinner?
Spaghetti.
Duo Villain sub!
Akasupa, stop it!
No, please.
Oh my god, there's so many superchats.
Thank you guys!
The sounds of the wind in the background are relaxing, right?
I was saying though...
Probably after Indiana Jones...
I know this might be a longer series too, but I think I want to...
It will be in combination with like...
You know...
Devil May Cry.
And like all the series that I've got going on and everything.
But I think I want to do...
I want to start... I want to try Nier.
So...
Just signed up for my first signed cheque lottery.
Wait, for who?
For who?
Serpentine belt broke, so no heat and engine is melting.
Made it to a tiny town and have been waiting in a bar for 45 minutes.
One hour to go with a shitty charger at half charge.
Water and...
What's that?
Just slick.
It's past the time.
Makes me appreciate having streamed with you, so thanks.
I hope that you get home soon and safe.
When will memberships be available in the US?
Have you tried signalist?
Yeah, I have played that before.
Replicant or automata?
I haven't done enough research yet.
So I cannot say which one.
It also depends on how I feel.
If I'm like...
Because one of them is a prequel, right?
But it's a prequel sequel.
Replicant is the first game.
Did it come out first?
Oh no?
I'm silly?
It's a remake of the first one.
I don't have to play Drakengard, right?
I guess I'll just miss out on some references.
It'd be cool though.
Drakengard is crazy.
No one should play Drakengard.
I had a friend who... it was her favorite game series.
And this is before Nier ever came out.
And I was like, girl...
You're into some freaky stuff.
Nier series also made by ex-Ace Combat dev.
No, I'm with the...
No matter what, there's an Ace Combat relation.
It's like, what's it called?
You know when you have the...
2 degrees to whatever or something, something.
I'm 3 degrees away from an Ace Combat reference.
Or dev or something.
Kevin Bacon.
6 degrees of separation.
It's Kevin Bacon.
6 degrees of Kevin Bacon.
7 degrees of Ace Combat.
What if I just...
Why won't it let me...
You can
play Automata without playing Replicant.
Yeah.
I have heard that.
I just think... I don't want...
Well, I can, you know...
Here's the thing.
You can never please everybody.
But I feel like...
If I don't play Replicant first, people will be like...
So... I don't know.
Automata has a lot of Replicant spoilers.
So it's like you either play it or you don't.
Sounds like it.
Oh, look at this guy right here.
And this guy over here.
Are these all skulls?
I thought it was treasure before.
Oh, let me get my dinner time away.
Alright.
Can you on Twitter?
Okay.
Please do.
I like these guys.
They are so funny.
Oh, I do not have... What's it called anymore?
Oh shoot.
No parry.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
Come here.
Focus in on this guy first maybe.
Oh wait.
No, no, no.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
He's almost down.
Nice!
Oh
gosh.
Give me a second to like...
Oh gosh.
Oh my god!
Oh big!
Big!
Big damage!
Dodge!
That was impressive though.
Holy crap.
Thank you!
Alright.
My buddy.
Oh shoot.
Move!
No, alright.
Okay.
Nice!
Take it down!
You jerk!
Dodge!
Wait, can I get back on... Oh I did not realize he was down this entire time.
That's so disappointing.
Oh, I could've gotten him!
Wait, let me get the other guy.
Oh!
I keep missing my chances!
Oh my god.
I'm
fine.
I can't see anything.
Please!
Oh
my god.
Please.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
I can't see anything.
I can't see.
Time for big damage though.
Oh my god.
Big damage!
Do
I just jump those?
Do I just jump to avoid those?
So close again.
I dodged too early.
See?
Jumping got the iframes.
Okay.
It's cause I get, you know, into like the...
Oh, I dodged again too early.
Speaking of...
Maybe we'll go after this guy first.
You know what?
Nice.
Oh wait.
When did I switch?
I was
going after you first.
Oh my god.
He's already down.
Oh, they're both down.
You know what?
Let's just get them both down.
So that it should be easier to kill one of them.
You know?
Oh shoot!
Let's do this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, now we're gonna focus on him.
Now we focus on him?
Oh no, no!
You, you, you.
No, no, no.
You focus on you?
Okay.
Nice parry
I didn't even get to...
That was stupid
Rachel, thanks for the 5 gifted
No, they are so funny No
Impressive No talking!
Let them speak!
Let Agni and Rudra speak!
Let my little yappers yap!
I love them Agni and Rudra are dragons from the Breath of Fire series.
Also made by Capcom Yomito, how are you liking DMC3?
I love it!
So much fun!
Blazed with serrated edges that hurl forth fire and tornado-like gusts You can equip when you start a mission...
Nice
It's the worst thing you can say about a Vtuber Let my little yappers yap is how I feel about Vtubers when YouTube buffers Oh, I went the wrong way.
But actually that's fine Oh, my bad
Actually, the exit should be the end of it, right?
This should be the end of it What's my... Ok, my health is...
Why does he look like that?
S S C D S D!
C!
B!
Yippee!
Get it?
Nice Only on mission 5.
That's ok though Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Exiting the screen.
Yes Oh, good thing we... good thing I saved
Oh, thank you
Normal Oh, I see.
So if I did want to switch to easy... Ok, so that's how you select it I understand, I understand now Oh wait, I wanted to...
I think I was gonna call it there
Let's finish with a little eye candy, huh?
Oh my god, her skirt is so short So short!
But I love skirts with, like, biker shorts under This peak is so cute
Easy is for noobs, ya scrub.
That's why I'm not on easy!
I'm actually really glad that I didn't switch to easy Because even though the bosses take me, like, a couple tries...
They're not... They haven't been unreasonable, you know I feel like if I had been on easy I would have just been like, eh, whatever
Oh my god.
Damn, girl!
She's so awesome
Look at her skirt, it's so cute!
Six!
Hey, is that lady?
Are you ready?
That's lady!
Clear the trial and forge a new path.
Family ties Interesting.
How much money we got?
7000.
Not a lot Not a lot Not a lot of money
Oh wait, that's not what I meant.
Action
Jetstream?
Wait, they also have air hike!
Oh my god, it's 20000 though
This is what max level gunslinger looks like
Jetstream.
I miss him I miss him The air hike tax returns.
Yeah, that's why it said 20000 I was like, I noticed that the amount went up, so I was just... wait Or was it 20000 before?
No, it was 20000 before, wasn't it?
That's right.
It was 20000 before.
I do remember It was 20k?
Yeah Okay, nevermind Nevermind.
I stand corrected Minto, who is your favorite IMAZ 765 idol?
765?
I really like Takane, but I also really love Hibiki
If you buy the air hike, you can shoot the air hike This is the Riz chapter?
Is it long?
I really gotta pack You can reply... Oh, you can replay missions between streams to farm.
True!
It can be really short.
It's long It's pretty long.
Okay.
Alright, we'll do it next time then Next time!
Thank you guys!
Hopefully this made... I know it wasn't super duper long either, but hopefully it made up for my poor performance last time And we got through a couple bosses.
We got through, what, Cerberus?
Does the worm count as a boss?
Is mayonnaise an instrument?
I guess it doesn't count as a boss unless you get a thing from it, huh?
Worm is a boss It does technically count.
Yeah, only three missions today, but that's okay Three missions in three hours
Nobody wanted the centipede powers, so they just were like, it's a boss, but we don't need you And we got to see Jester.
That was fun Probably miss your Friday stream since that's when I'm flying to Atlanta So I just want to wish you good luck at the concert.
I have my life sticks ready Let's go!
I'll see you then!
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee Worm counts as a boss?
That sucks.
It sucks
I love the Touhou characters and music, but how does one get into Touhou?
I did buy a few games during the last Steam sale Stale?
Sale?
A lot of Touhou... I feel like Touhou is more fanon than canon So...
Really?
Just...
I don't know how I got into...
I'll be honest
I frequent a certain...
Wait, how do I say it?
Well, I frequent...
How I got into Touhou is so silly So I...
I would go on the image board site Danboru And I would see the characters on there And I was just like, they're so cute!
And so that's how... All I did was see the characters and be like Oh wow!
They're so cute!
I still use Danboru for like...
I use it for like inspo stuff For like outfits and everything And I use it for wallpapers
So yeah...
I don't know, I don't really know how you get into Touhou I think from there, then I was like... I found like the iosis You know
Like, you know, the music videos and listen to a lot of the music and stuff It really depends on what you want to get out of Touhou Guys, I think this is my third time asking, how many missions are in this game?
I forgot, I forgot to look at chat I ask a question sometimes and then I forget to look at chat, I'm really sorry 20!
Okay Okay We're on 6 Okay When I get back When I get back It's game time, baby It's game time Never change, Minto
Just watch Bad Apple recreated in every possible medium Yeah Minto gaming We're gaming, we're gonna game Yeah, yeah But, you know, even if this takes us a little longer than the other ones, that's okay too Maybe what, like 5, 6 streams maybe?
Good luck on your packing, Minto My flight is super early, but can't wait for Awa and your concert Yay, thank you Minto, congratulations on today's progress, by the way, tomorrow is my birthday I wonder if we could sing the Mother Base happy birthday version before I listen to KAI's tomorrow Of course Waseth,
is that how I say your name?
Happy birthday, congratulations Happy birthday with salutations Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue Happy birthday to you Waseth, happy birthday!
But I'm having so much fun, I'm having so much fun with this I'm glad that...
That I can at least...
Even for the quote-unquote most difficult DMC game, I can at least play and get through it Dante is so back, he's so silly, this game is so silly, I'm loving it You learn so much Is it better than DMC2?
No, nothing could be better than that
Nothing, nothing could beat my...
Everybody knows the best game in a series is with the silent protag
OK!
Guys!
Otsumita!
Thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys when I see you next, maybe at the concert?
If not, I wanted to make sure that I still streamed on Friday Because I know, of course, there's going to be so many people that can't also go to the concert And I don't want to just have my weekends all away and all focused on the concert But yeah, so Friday is for everybody,
you know, who can't make it I'll say it so, you know, say it Don't worry about us who can't go, but I do worry!
I do worry, especially when I see people being like, oh no, the phone will...
And I'm just like, I'm sorry, I'm sorry But we'll, like I said before, we'll be able to upload some of the performance online Yeah, like our favorite songs or something, so Yeah, yeah, yeah I'll make it to the next one, I promise Hopefully there will be many,
many more So if we can't make it to this one, hopefully there will be many, many more events and many, many more concerts Yeah So thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Otsumita!
I don't think I have anything else Yeah, see you guys!
Bye bye!
Itterasshai!
Thank you!
Bye bye!